what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and I'm writing this video one
day after we published the first best
revenge moments at anime it hasn't even
been 24 hours since its release and we
already hit well over the goal of 2,000
likes so here I am already working on a
part 2 as promised today I've compiled
some of the most savage revenge moments
known to man so you're in for a real
treat but there are still plenty of
revenge moments that I'd like to get to
so if the space fan can hit 3000 likes
on this video I'll get started on the
third installment which will be just as
epic so remember to hit that like button
for more sweet sweet revenge if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and ring
that notification bell so you actually
get notified when the next video
installment comes out remember this is
an ongoing series so don't get salty if
your favorite revenge moment isn't here
leave it in the comments and it could
appear in future installments it's
definitely one of my favorite ways of
learning about new anime so I definitely
encourage you guys to share your
favorites there will be animators in
this video you've been warned now
without further ado let's jump into it
first up let's take a look at my
favorite revenge moments in one of the
best anime ever created let's take a
closer look at Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and the fights between Roy
and lust and between Roy and NV although
they're more like executions rather than
fights like most revenge moments they
mean very little without context it is
precisely the moments outside of the act
of revenge itself that gives the
commenting moment so much impact so
let's set up the stakes and background
motivations for Roy Mustang the flame
Alchemist there's a lot of reasons for
Roy as a state Alchemist to hate the
homunculus which are artificial
superhuman creatures each of which
represent one of the seven deadly sins
aside from the fact that they kill
innocent humans and our threat to
humanity in general Roy has some very
personal reasons for hating them you see
Mustangs best friend inside and outside
the military was Mays Hughes Mays
uplifting personality is one of the
lights shining through in an otherwise
deeply corrupted dark world while Roy
can be pretty gloomy Mays is a ball of
positivity and support he's always
calling or stopping
to see Roy he's always talking about how
great his wife and daughter are I don't
think it's a stretch to say that he's
one of the most likable characters in
all of anime so what happens to Roy's
best friend this likable family man well
he gets brutally murdered at the age of
29 May he's always wanting to help his
best friend Roy and others found out too
much about the corruption in the
military and one day lust showed up to
kill him
he got wounded but managed to escape
from her thanks to some quick thinking
on his part he makes it to a payphone
and tries to call his friend Mustang in
order to tell him what he's discovered
then Andy shows up pretending to be
lieutenant Maria Roz Macy's through this
but he's got a gun pointed at him and he
can just shoot him but he doesn't he
uses his shape-shifting powers to
transform into Hugh's wife first
so that Hughes cannot bring himself to
hurt him then as he promised and he
plays out
Hugh's worst nightmare he makes it look
like his own wife shot him he didn't
just kill him and be mentally tortured
Hugh's a nice family man and ended his
life in the worst way possible by using
the image of his loving wife in order to
kill him
thus Roy had a lot of reason to hate
both lost and and me they both work
together in order to kill his best
friend a good guy who deserves to stay
alive if anyone did Roy always wanted
Hughes to be there by his side Hugh's
always said that he would support
Mustang by working under him after his
death Mustang finally understands why
Alphonse and Edward tried to bring their
mother back
Mustang wishes he could do the same with
Hughes then we get one of the most
touching moments in the series after
being asked if he's alright
Roy says he's fine he puts his hat over
his eyes and says it's starting to rain
Hawkeye says it's not raining because it
isn't then we see tears coming down this
usually calm cool and collected man's
face he says yes it is this is rain he
doesn't want to cry he knows a grown man
in his position shouldn't but he just
can't help it unlike Hughes Mustang
doesn't have a family of his own Hughes
his best friend was the closest thing he
had to family and now he's gone it's too
much for even a stern guy like Mustang
to bear he decides that he must avenge
Hughes by finding his killer
and making them pay no matter what so
let's fast forward now to the moments of
revenge
we start with lust lust not only played
a part in killing Hughes she also used
one of Roy's most trustworthy
subordinates gene havoc pretending to be
interested in him romantically in order
to get information then when lust roid
entity is revealed to Roy and havoc she
impales havoc with her sharp fingers and
he collapses from the wounds she then
stabs Roy leaving them both for dead and
makes her escape lost then attempts to
kill hawkeye who is the queen to Roy's
king she is easily the most important
person in Roy's life at this point
however Alphonse protects Hawkeye long
enough for Roy to show up Alphonse
builds a stone wall for protection and
then Roy goes ham with his fire powers
on lust he says to gain the initiative
and war first take away your enemy's
mobility and whenever possible use the
element of surprise then he points out
to lust that she's finally on her knees
there are quite a few badass things
going on here for starters Roy is only
still alive because he used fire to sear
his wounds closed that's an extremely
painful process and he almost passed out
two or three times doing it then since
he doesn't have his glove he cut a trans
mutating circle into his own skin he
keeps firing off his flame attacks
unrelentingly this is one of the most
savage moments in all of anime Roy keeps
going and says he'll keep killing her
until she stays dead all of a sudden
near immortality has become a curse
because it allows Roy to torture lust
over and over again then she extends her
finger in order to stab Roy's face Roy
being the boss that he is doesn't even
flinch the finger stops right in front
of his face then lust begins to turn to
ashes
Roy is so cool that even the enemy he
just killed says that if she had to die
she's glad it was at the hands of a man
like him in the anime this episode is
called death of the undying
and that's exactly what Roy and his
fiery rage managed to do he managed to
kill the seemingly unkillable in order
to execute his revenge then there's
enemies demise and enemy is the one who
actually finished huzzah so you can be
sure that Roy won't go easy on him
a reason that chapter 94 of the manga
and episode 53 a brotherhood are called
the flames of vengeance it's because the
flame Alchemist finally gets that a
person who cruelly took away hues from
this world and all of the people in it
in the manga this revenge moment was
built up over almost 80 chapters so you
can bet it's gonna be rewarding after
hunting for Hugh's killer throughout the
series Roy finally comes face to face
with him he tells scar and Al that Envy
is his prey and he tells Hawkeye to stay
back
he starts launching his onslaught of
flames he tells enemy to hurry up and
heal so he can make him suffer
excruciating pain again and again until
he stays dead enemy however escapes and
Roy goes chasing after him then NB does
the worst possible thing he can do He
pours salt on the wound by
shape-shifting into hues to get to Roy
however Roy is not as easily affected by
this ploy as Hughes was Roy without
hesitating attacks this creature who
looks like his best friend as he says
the mockery doesn't help envy it just
adds oil to Roy's fire of revenge
Roy alternates between pinpoint attacks
and full force explosions so Envy cannot
get close to him and he has no choice
but to escape again
then enemy turns into Roy and tries to
get close to Hawkeye she sees through
the ruse but and be man just to hurt her
and plans to beat her like a rag doll
before returning her to Mustang
I mean Envy is really doing everything
he can in order to piss off Mustang
which is why it's even more satisfying
when he suddenly engulfed in flames
he asks what NB is doing to his precious
subordinate in the manga Roy completely
Dwarfs Envy in the panel it really shows
how powerless Envy is in the face of
Roy's overwhelming fury and B calls him
a human scum who dares to look down on a
homunculus but must thing just keeps
going he utterly destroys enemies
powerful homunculus form and enemy
reverts back to a small worm like
creature Roy is about to finish the
powerless creature off for good and me
is screaming no and is crying before
Hawkeye points are gone to Roy Mustang
doesn't end up finishing the pitiful
creature off because his friends
including Hawkeye and Edward won't let
him completely
him into his rage and become a monster
yet somehow this is even more satisfying
because that's exactly what Envy wants
for humans to give in to their base
instincts and their hatred he is a proud
creature that looks down on humans as if
they were worms ironic I know
then when he tries to bait them into
getting angry at each other and it
doesn't work and even shows compassion
towards the ugly pitiful creature this
to envy is the ultimate insult and he
rips out his philosopher's stone which
is the equivalent to ripping out his own
heart it was the perfect revenge
precisely because it was the best
possible way to humiliate and infuriate
this extremely proud homunculus Hughes
was avenged and Roy got to hold on to
his humanity at the same time
then there's gone insane transformation
in Hunter hunter along with being one of
the greatest revenge moments in anime it
is also one of the darkest and most
savage let's recap some of the more
important points we need to know to
fully appreciate this moment one of the
keys to understanding this moment is the
character kite kite was very special
forgone because he was gone father's
student if you didn't know hunter hunter
is all about going searching for his
father what we think about ging and how
good of a father he is aside the fact
remains that go and grew up without him
like most kids probably would go and
developed a strong desire to see him and
make him proud since gang was largely
absent from his life going greatly
values not only his father's presence
but anything or anyone that is connected
to his father in one way or another this
is in part why kite is such a big deal
kite was ging student and by extension
he immediately has immense value in
gongs eyes
he's like a proxy father figure or at
the very least an older brother figure
for the young boy now I don't mean to
suggest that kite didn't also become a
really good friend of gongs in his own
right but I just want to point out that
this connection to gongs father colors
the way Gong views kite and greatly
amplifies the feelings of friendship
gone develops for him
so while gone already greatly values his
friends kite is valued all the more
because he in a way helps fill the hole
that Gaughan's father left with his
absence
thus when kite who has been presented as
being extremely strong gets wrecked and
killed by
Peto it's a really really big deal for
going before Peto showed up chi told
both gone and kilowatt to run but gone
didn't do it
then Peter shows up and takes off kites
arm they see how strong she is and gone
instead of running away starts powering
up he can't bring himself to leave kite
it takes kill one knocking him out to
get going away go never would have
willingly abandoned kite the strongest
connection he has to his father
then after kite gets killed he gets
turned into a training dummy when they
retrieve his body gone thinks that the
real kite might still be alive in there
despite how horribly disfigured his body
is Gordon tries to reason with the doll
but kites body punches him in the face
as soon as he gets close this is no
doubt one of the most tragic parts in
the show even though he must be in a lot
of pain after the punch he doesn't get
mad at all and tries to approach kite
again he doesn't want to believe that he
could be dead however going just keeps
getting brutally beat up by the kite
doll everyone else knows that kite is
dead and there's no chance of bringing
him back but they're waiting for gone to
notice the same thing go and even
suppresses his reflexes to dodge or
block purposely allowing himself to be
hit he eventually accepts that kites
body is moving like a robot and that
it's much weaker than kite used to be he
hugs the body and apologizes to kite he
blames himself for what happened he
blames himself for what deep down he
must know is the death of a friend and
for the death of his father's precious
student he not only feels like he failed
his friend he also feels like he failed
his father the one person whose approval
he wants more than anything else
kite is one of the closest things going
has to family at this point and Peto not
only killed him
but even desecrated the body and memory
of him yet going at this point still
can't even bring himself to consciously
accept that kite is dead and so he holds
out hope that Peto still might be able
to heal him and bring him back to normal
then after patiently waiting for Peto to
start healing kite she finally says that
she can't do it and the usually cheery
and carefree gone finally snaps now
everything I just mentioned is what's
behind the final confrontation between
Gorn and Pete oh go on is so devastated
that he doesn't even care about
surviving or in a future he just wants
to carry out his revenge so he uses
everything he's got at once even if it
means losing the ability to ever use
that again or even dying and transforms
into an Opie adult gone who according to
Peto is as strong as the Chimera ant
king himself in this form gone so angry
and committed to revenge that he did
something I've never seen before he
forced his body to mature to a point
where he's able to defeat a much more
powerful opponent the innocent shown and
protagonist says that he is going to
kill someone who doesn't even want to
fight this revenge is so savage that
guns punches don't just break through
PTO's bones they break through Shonen
conventions for instance you'd never see
Edward Elric acting like this go and
sacrifice his innocence symbolize
further by the maturing of his physical
body in order to carry out this revenge
as I said in the previous video the best
revenge moments usually require a lot of
sacrifice and here gone is right to
sacrifice everything and because of the
sacrifice he makes he reaches a power
where he effortlessly overpowers Peto by
even more than she overpowered kite even
after her body is broken
gong keeps punching the body over and
over again with his bloody knuckles her
remaining men turns her lifeless body
into a puppet and launches an attack
that catches going off guard and takes
his arm Gulen feels redeemed because
kite also lost his arm protecting him
and kill one then go on takes his arm
and jams it through PTO's body and
launches a giant attack that looks more
like a spirit bomb than any move from
Hunter hunter kite has been thoroughly
avenged in the most savage way possible
and the moment is even more impactful
when we think about how innocent gone
used to be now we get to Sasuke the
embodiment of revenge itself and
shonan's number one emo this guy is
always trying to get revenge on someone
whether it's the right person or not
however one revenge moment sticks out as
being especially satisfying as we know
from the beginning of the series
Sasuke wanted to get revenge on his
brother for killing his entire clan
however after he finally succeeds in
doing it he finds out that he was
mistaken the whole time Sasuke's brother
Itachi was arguably the hero in this
situation
the hidden leaf village used to get rid
of doji hock clan who posed an imminent
threat to the entire village knowing
that the Chi Hawk clan was planning to
threaten the well-being of the hidden
leaf village
Itachi decided to wipe out his entire
clan and become the most hated villain
of the village in order to save that
very village and most importantly his
little brother Sasuke despite how he did
it all to protect his low brother
Sasuke devoted his life to killing him
and eventually he did kill him because
he thought she planned for that to
happen all along he never wanted Sasuke
to find out the truth he wanted Sasuke
to be the hero who killed the villain of
the hidden leaf village
however Sasuke does find out what
happened and he is understandably even
more upset because he was tricked into
killing the person who loved him the
most in the entire world while the
people who were the most guilty namely
the higher-ups in the hidden leaf
village got away scot-free
Danzo out of everyone was the biggest
offender he played the biggest role in
convincing Itachi to kill his clansmen
in order to save his brother as if this
wasn't bad enough this would Chi ha
hater also desecrated the bodies of many
many Chi hah and implanted their eyes
into him all over his body
so he is a living walking insult to do
Chi ha in the mastermind behind their
deaths he taught his faith and Sasuke's
initial ignorance so if you thought
Sasuke hated Itachi in the beginning of
the series I think you can now start to
imagine how much more he has come to
hate Danzo that brings us to their fight
even though Sasuke keeps killing Danzo
Danzo keeps coming back to life and he's
using the power of the stolen hoochie
High's to do it he then even insults
Sasuke he doesn't understand why Tashi
would sacrifice himself to save the life
of such trash he says that Sasuke was
with that a doubt Itachi's biggest
mistake I mentioned in the previous
revenge video that revenge is all the
more satisfying when the enemy is an
Opie nearly invincible dude
Danzo definitely fits the opie category
he has many Sharingan that he can use to
change fate itself via Izanagi he turns
out to have hashirama cells so he has
jeha powers hashirama powers and he was
just a strong fighters to begin with
even before all these significant
upgrades
thus the criteria
for a truly epic revenge moment has been
met zosky just needs to find a way to
defeat him but for a moment it seems
like Sasuke lost the idea is that as
long as Danzo has Sharingan is left to
use izanagi even a mutual hint will
result in danzo's win because he can
undo anything disadvantageous to himself
while not erasing his own attacks so
when the two are about to hit each other
Danzo thinks he won because he still has
one eye left it seems like he got the
win and just when Sasuke's revenge seems
out of reach it is revealed that Sasuke
was a step ahead of him and used an
illusion AKA genjutsu to trick Danzo
into thinking he had one more eye on his
arm when in fact he actually did not so
the attack penetrating danzo's body is
not undone by the Izanagi karin let
Sasuke bite her to help him recover from
some of his damage it's weird I know but
the point is she really cares about
Sasuke and it's always there to help him
for these reasons
Danzo assumes he can use her as a
hostage in a last-ditch effort he takes
her thinking Sasuke will be unable to
attack because an attack might hit his
friend
however Danzo completely underestimates
just how important Sasuke's revenge is
to him not only does he not try to avoid
hitting Karin he even tells her not to
move then in the manga we get a close-up
of Sasuke's face which I have to say is
one of the most messed up images in all
of Naruto it is clear that this guy has
given in to his hatred and will do
anything for revenge at this point he
fires an attack straight through his
teammate and into Danzo vital point then
he says one down big brother with a
smile on his face this is how savage
Sasuke is not only is he rate the
sacrifice his friends
he wouldn't even bat an eye or hesitate
at this point he is a guy that would
give just about anything for his revenge
and Danzo after everything he's done is
the best possible target for his hatred
lastly Danzo is dying a collateral
damage sealing jutsu gets released from
his body that drags anyone in the
vicinity into his body trapping them
inside however Sasuke escapes in time
his fellow chi-ha currently going by the
name Madara says and I quote
that was close in contrast Sasuke
doesn't even give almost being sealed
for eternity a second thought
he just says now onward to Konoha aka
the hidden leaf village this is why
Sasuke is like the perfect Avenger even
though he just took revenge on arguably
the worst enemy ever Abdul Chi ha and
he's extremely injured he wants to
immediately move on to the next stage of
his revenge that's all he can think
about although you can say a lot of bad
stuff about Sasuke his commitment to
revenge is definitely one of the most
interesting parts of Naruto at least for
me and that is it for the best revenge
moments in anime 2 which are trying to
fill with some of the most savage
revenge moments ever obviously there are
many more epic revenge moments that I
have yet to break down so if you want to
see more make sure to smash that like
button if we get 3000 likes I'll make a
part 3 if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell so you actually get notified when
you videos drop for more anime greatness
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime out drawer a big thank you goes
out to our patrons over on patreon who
help make videos like this one possible
I especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons don't one-and-only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
kings I'll just angel Cruz steelers poet
Pablo
atropos Wraith Michael fiddler in
akhirat Gianna and are the one to your
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Stephen and Radha a Lola not M
Maddie Mac 239 and makoto-kun
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to
patreon.com/scishow op drawer and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord
so check out patreon.com slash anime
uproar link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer no matter what
you want to do you'll still get all the
same great benefits thanks again for
everything as I'm recording this we just
hit over half a million
subscribers which is absolutely amazing
so I really want to thank you guys for
that it would not be possible without
the space fam so thank you thank you
thank you so much for that and until
next time see you space cowboy
[Music]